en entre temps devenu ministre alors
vous dites que vous êtes devenu ministre
la pac la politique agricole commune
avant d'être ministre à c'était de
l'hébreu la dioxine du chinois
alors on va passer la question qui tue
mais avant mais avant je dois dire un
email de florent la base qui aimerait
bien que la question qui tue dure plus
longtemps parce qu'il dit cette lumière
est très érotique
quand il est chez lui se finirait très
érotique voire pornographique ça vous
intéresserait à l ena et alors ils me
demandent aussi de dire à camille qu'il
aime tant qu'ami il t'aime voilà jean
glavany
c'est très simple on se souvient n'en
profite pas à laurent parce qu'il fait
nuit on se souvient du nuage de
tchernobyl qui s'était arrêté à la
frontière franco allemande
alors concernant la sphère de la vache
folle est ce qu aurait des choses qu'on
me ses pannes français oui c'est pas
parce que vous des cachets ont laissé
pape vous le savez pas non plus mais
c'est pas aussi je ne sais pas non plus
mais c'est pas parce que tu ne le savent
pas non plus il n'ya pas des choses que
vous savez aujourd'hui je vois rien des
choses granon dit romieu pas le dire aux
gens parce que non ça va être la
psychose nationale rien c'est sûr
certains
donc vous dites y'a rien français que
vous ne sachiez pas sociable
non vraiment franchement rien très bien
on va lui
mm
certaine manière le problème qui nous
est posée c'est comme quand on dit tout
et donc on en sait trop bien